the resolution for vote of no confidence
against mr imran khan the prime minister
of islamic republic of pakistan has been
passed voted out by a majority imran
khan has become the first prime minister
of pakistan to be ousted by a
no-confidence motion the date
significant throughout pakistan's
political history
10th april 1973
may is housed in a
1973 constitution co-proof kiev
10th april
2022
welcome back
to purana pakistan
welcome back to the old pakistan he says
a dig at imran khan slogan for a new
pakistan
the end of his premiership celebrated by
some with fireworks and dancing in the
street
[Applause]
it all happened as the clock struck
midnight the vote finally taking place
imran khan testing the resolve of
pakistan's institutions to the last the
parliament the judiciary and even the
military sky news has learned that the
chief of army staff and the isi chief
paid him a late night visit asking him
to settle the political stalemate
imran khan held on till the bitter end
buying himself time but not enough last
week the deputy speaker attempted to
save him by rejecting the vote then he
himself called for elections asking the
president to dissolve the national
assembly in preparation
the opposition cried foul and took it to
the supreme court it was ruled
unconstitutional not the judgment and
legacy the leader of the proudly named
party for justice would have wanted
and it's not the dignified exit he could
have had threatened with contempt of
court subverting the constitution and
parliamentary procedure and in the end
making way for the opposition he vowed
to keep out and hold accountable for
corruption
a fall from grace for an icon of
pakistan imran khan is not only down and
out he's taken his party with him simon
morsin sky news lahore